[Music]
because of this Covey's yeah Kobe in
China China at the same correct
so because of students being quarantined
there in Wuhan and other areas they have
figured out that if you give enough like
one star or negative reviews on this one
Alibaba app which is where they're
getting their homework from then
eventually hopefully they will boot that
app out of the store and so they can't
do homework so all these school children
they're getting fake homework from
Alibaba not fake so a lot of schools
I've joined this Alibaba app yeah and so
that's how schools are giving homework
and doing classes like online classes
with their their kit like the classmates
yeah so these kids they ended up
deciding like oh my gosh what the [ __ ]
like we're all pointing we can't even
get a break like we could possibly be
dying but we stopped to do homework what
if we get this app kicked off the App
Store so then it'll like we won't have
to do homework anymore so they all Bend
together and in one day that store went
from like a four point nine out of five
stars to one point four stars more gifts
my kids say that I would give them some
other [ __ ] homework to do that's true
they better hope they got the homeworks
working if they're genius though that's
pretty smart [ __ ] them kids but didn't
they do something smart even though [ __ ]
those kids yeah okay except if you like
all the creative of Alibaba be like what
the [ __ ] is happening right now Jack Ma
I think in respecting tuck now it's a
here's kids don't have homework to keep
them occupied so they're bugging him
right so you think that we think that's
nice you think that's no don't send in
my place I'm just saying I can respect
what they did respect respect condom
it's cunning who's coming respect
condoms I
that's what I respect [ __ ] these kids
okay like tens of thousands of reviews
flooded in and like I said overnight the
reading plummeted excusing and then so
they're just saying like dude what the
[ __ ]
so the app called ding talk they were
also saying like please don't kill us
we're only five years old ourselves
people who have jobs ran these punk-ass
kids are trying to ruin it think about
it they're ruining they didn't want to
do homework he's like yo if you went
school you'll still be doing the
homework don't wait a look at American
kids aren't getting either yes so for
Isaac school I got an email or a phone
call to last week saying that okay
starting Thursday which is today that we
have to log on to our emails because
Isaac has a Google Google classroom and
luckily we had like a Chromebook at home
so he can use that to log on and yeah
today is when the teachers giving
instructions on they're calling it
distance distant learning so he's gonna
be doing that up until he goes back to
school and then they're saying like
there was a press conference where the
California Governor said that don't
expect students to go back to school
before summer break so a lot of girls
aren't even getting the chance to
graduate yeah my cousin was supposed to
graduate and is super bummed because he
they might not be able to like walk and
like get the diploma yeah I think what
the kids who can't graduate because they
didn't make the grade they're like yes
or like prom and like all those things
that everyone usually a senior stuff
that you normally get to do I had this
one company because of the prompting
they were like doing a raffle for kids
all over LA County and la proper and
they're going to hold the prom for them
and they're gonna get literally get if
everybody has muscles so they will be
protected I'm not at all I believed you
when I saw your little like lip curl up
and I'm like that's the to hear like
what pictures getting funny on fire in
his brain
I like it but you know there's already a
service for this is called Space Camp
just send everyone to Space Camp I don't
give you suits they don't give you sleep
bullsh is that space get sucks it's like
up in a tree like they have ropes and
like you walk out a catwalk up in a what
I thought they got you want to [ __ ] you
this guy ro thing the only thing I want
to do I did at this face camp an
aviation camp like an aviation camp well
it would like right next to his space
and aviation is still earth yeah so they
did the assimilation of you're in a
helicopter crashing into a pool of water
so like there's just like this this
fuselage that you're in yeah and it
ducks you in this pool you have to like
get out of the seat melted enough time
there's an instructor with you but like
I was in high school no I was in middle
school when this happened and I was like
okay wow I don't think you know that's
aviation camp that was aviation camp
yeah is you crashing yeah you gotta be
okay because we all they did like the 3G
test like you can go up to like four G's
or some flavor to the simulator then
when that guy spins around you feel the
pressure like you literally feel some
water today if people blackout and
everything like it was great
I bought get stuck to the back of your
head yeah yeah yes what kid came out
with no eyeballs they're like oh
Beetlejuice crazy as [ __ ] there's crazy
time yeah back there was like sounds
like all these camps are just set up to
terrify kids that are not wanting to do
this [ __ ] yeah I don't think about like
it's just right now like how bad is
their helicopter situation are gonna be
yeah I mean granted like like the doors
will open like on a real helicopter was
like dude like what I'm like the buckle
would something would happen now stuck
underneath water people in pool too like
just the case of the words joining us to
put you through the hardship so that one
actually happens oh cool comfort zone
sure as I can sedan CD when you're
younger yeah
when you get it again your pee-hole
burns I did this with an instructor
estimation wise was trying to flirt with
the guy you had a crush on because we're
like all the way from home and they were
staying in like different room you would
like yeah
childhood of my dream I know I think
I've no space came I saw it on
commercial fall in love with the Space
Camp intro no I wanted to go to Space
Camp period as a child I wanted to go to
camps like that it always seemed like so
fun and I did end up going to one but
then later on I realized that that was
like that campus but like specifically
for underprivileged children Oh Rose
like oh [ __ ] I would support you to
discount Space Camp
yeah it was only it was a bit of a box
rockets and bingo they make it they
making a rocket out of a dishwasher box
like Nagisa everything getting canceled
Isaac was supposed to go to this really
really cool STEM program like summer
camp thing where he was actually gonna
be spending the night like for a whole
week he was gonna be at a dorm somewhere
here and now they I forgot the school
already but one of the universities and
they were gonna have astronauts be
keynote speakers and like some really
dope [ __ ]
and it cancelled it because of this so
my dad was crazy and so this program you
can only get invited if your teacher
recommends you oh it was like getting
the Harry Potter letter in the mail I
was like oh my god and so now that we
found out it's canceled were like oh we
just reschedule it but yeah they can
have the astronaut to talk to them via
videoconferencing for what the [ __ ] do I
know I'm just so [ __ ]
I mean it Kudo yeah I mean I don't think
that's top priority I'm experienced
yeah and it's not top priority I don't
mean like what I was gonna do right now
that he's already in space and didn't
[ __ ] I probably the place to be or
populate Mars so that they don't have to
be on this earth anymore yeah if you
could go to space to get away from this
right now would you go no they don't
have like Google up there like they all
have a book just like of YouTube oh yeah
I guess I wouldn't
you do the derry-o the hell yeah I think
they post it is it going to the forest
right now kind of like going to space
like you don't really see anybody over
there
now there's barely [ __ ] they have Cocoa
Beach bears in space there's no light
flow there's there's no gravity in space
oh I thought you're just talking about
like that distancing and the sickness
infectious distance I get what you're
saying I got what you're saying yeah but
like there are animals in the forest you
still have to deal with that and then
like what like a really really really
really tall tree house did you guys
watch love is blind oh they go live in a
tree house for like a day it is so dope
it's like the coolest tree house I'm so
clumsy I would be afraid of killing
myself just like walking outside in the
trees yeah or in space in normal life
yeah mainly the tree house though dude
imagine living on Mars though and like
you actually open a window think about
the first total recall' will Autosports
and Egger
yeah am when they were outside anything
bars that's automatically the Emma tech
notes who is that first Total Recall
yeah yeah that's a lot of coverage is
what I thought for the longest time
because of media movies and [ __ ] is that
when you're in space if an astronaut
took off your helmet you immediately
freeze to death like immediately like
instantly but it's not the case
your body is already has its own warmth
and so you sort of just cool down over
time and then freeze to death well it's
not like no but there's no oxygen no
oxygen yes you immediately so yeah right
so you're but you're but I thought you
take off your bed and then you're frozen
like that's like dead where else the way
yes no is no it's not oxygen so you
suffocate
but if you hold your breath you're gonna
right no cuz there's also no gravity so
your whole face just starts melting and
liquefying yeah because your face is
actually in the fluids are made for
gravity so there's a way like your face
sits that makes no but that doesn't make
sense because it would be like
yeah yeah so there's so there's no
matter there's no air there's no
particles and there's no gravity so like
the the gravity which keeps like this
equilibrium between your skin and your
membranes it's not there anymore so all
the water's just going everywhere no
exactly it evaporates it like sucked in
tear like nah bro if an astronaut could
take his helmet off in space and his
face is not liquefied
yeah exactly arts to change liquify bro
it takes hours so water doesn't go
everywhere go to take your helmet off
Shelley what that was real skull like
how does your skull just like like you
know what I'm buddy hours and hours of
process well that's why they pressurize
everything yeah the airlock thing when
they open airlock [ __ ] and then like
they just kind of like implode right
yeah eyeball starts well according to
google an astronaut without a suit will
last about 15 seconds before losing
consciousness from lack of oxygen
and that's all over it so far but you
still gotta breath if you go 17 seconds
not [ __ ] that Tom Cruise can laugh
longer than that he taught us something
like hold his breath for like four
minutes for that I think was like six
minutes yes I'll hit me good no 'evil
ISM would results in the formation of
bubbles in the moisture found in the
eyes mouth and skin tissue and they're
saying that one NASA subject test
subject to survived in 1965 exit oh my
god in which he was exposed to near
vacuum conditions and he felt the saliva
on his tongue began to boil before he
lost consciousness after 14 seconds wait
begin to boil how hot is that space was
cold why was it boil that's physics is
crazy it's so cold it gets hot and
there's no ozone layer so then the sun's
feeling a really intense order you can
get sunburned out there yeah you're
saying that you hold wedding hugs too
much harm in just 15 seconds even if
that's because heat leaves the body very
slowly in a vacuum the more likely the
more likely damage would be a space
hickey caused from the swelling and
burst of the skin small blood vessels
space picky
okay now let's try a snotty now let's
try to guess how a microwave works what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]